Ebola is a highly infectious virus that attacks the internal organs.
Symptoms include fever, weakness, diarrhea, vomiting and bleeding.
The disease is spread through contact with bodily fluids of infected animals and humans.
Fruit bats are considered the natural host of the virus.
Ebola first appeared in the DRC and Sudan in 1976.
Outbreaks occur mainly in rural areas in Central and West Africa in the tropical rainforests.
The current outbreak is the deadliest and the most widespread.
It started in Guinea in March this year and has spread to Sierra Leone and Liberia.
More than 930 people have been killed by the deadly virus...
...and that number continues to rise.
The fatality rate is as high as 90 percent and there is currently no known cure.